au nord de marseille la colline de
mouret piane c'est dans ce quartier que
claire hélène et son compagnon jean
marie ont choisi de bâtir leur étrange
maison
[Musique]
claire hélène est architecte pour
construire le moins cher possible
elle a puisé l'inspiration juste en face
de chez elle dans le port de marseille
elle a décidé d'utiliser les containers
maritimes en fonction des besoins du
garage salle d'eau etc
on sait on s'est fait une aile avec
trois petits containers donc voilà on a
un deux trois ça fait combien de comptes
au néon bouton on tourne en a 15 ans
voilà cinq containers par par niveau ce
qui donne une surface de plancher de 100
m² 100 mètres carrés sur trois niveaux
300 m² au total il y vivent depuis deux
ans mais les travaux ne sont pas encore
terminées c'est chez nous ici on se
retrouve dans ce que j'appelle à la
colonne vertébrale de la maison où on a
le poil au rez de chaussée avec un tuyau
qui s'élève sur 7 mètres cinquante donc
échelle de mener pas très pratique pour
le moment avec ces containers claire
hélène a réalisé un tour de force
construire 300 m² pour moins de 200
mille euros c'est deux fois moins cher
qu'une maison traditionnelle
voilà on est en haut et là c'est le
volet main je vous invite à apprécier ce
volet mois vous allez garder au maximum
cette apparence rutelli qu way
métallique et industriels on va
conserver au maximum le plancher ça
c'est donc ces deux containers c'est la
couleur d'origine
on peut le voir d'ailleurs parce qu'on a
pas repeint cet endroit donc on voit les
traces et razer ruine et trace les
cicatrices du container un style
singulier dont elle est fière un budget
maîtrisé
c'est ainsi que claire-hélène a réalisé
son rêve de propriétaire
le gamin c'est un terrain qui nous sert
à étendre le linge très pratique on a pu
temps des cordes entre les crochets qui
ont été conservés ce données offertes
par le container c'est pas beau la vie
comme elle de nombreux français sont
prêts à explorer de nouvelles pistes
pour acheter leur logement y compris les
plus inattendus à paris sven et marianne
habite depuis peu dans cet appartement
un quatre pièces ultra design acheter au
prix cassés de 495 1000 euros une
aubaine pour qui connaît les prix de la
capitale mais un tel tarif cache quelque
chose
ça fait 90 m² bongo dont 88 quelque
chose comme ça sur plusieurs niveaux
donc en loi car elle en revanche on est
à 34 mètres carrés ce qu'on ne
comptabilise que la mezzanine et la
pièce principale
le secret de l'appartement de marianne
sa plus grande partie se situe sous
terre 56 m² au niveau des caves et puis
en bas on a nos deux champs celle de la
petite et puis la nôtre et et la salle
de bain et les toilettes
on appelle cela un souplex est-ce que
c'était décidemment nous quand on a
acheté ce terrain local de réserve et a
apparemment la chambre de la petite
c'était une espèce de labo on sépare on
à jour n'a jamais vraiment su y avait
des traces de comme les traces de
rouille alors qu aurait pu être un faux
quand la bonne chimie sont conseillés
par une fenêtre
c'est une fois ce fenêtre en fait cdc
des blagues c'est pour faire semblant
fait ya un derrière un mur qui est pas
très beau qui est tout près du puits des
petites lumières ou encore celle là
c'est pas celle qui fait le plus
sensation c'est surtout celle qui est
dans la chambre où il ya la lumière
fait une lumière assez douces et ça
c'est vraiment un moyen d'avoir pas
l'impression d'être dans un dans un
sous-sol aveugle face à un mur en béton
et chez marianne les lampes reste
allumée en permanence
mais au delà du manque de lumière le
vrai problème en souplex celle absence
d'aérations semaine nous a acheté un
extraordinaire purificateurs d'air
extrêmement puissant voilà qu'on fait
tourner de temps en temps dans sa
chambre parfois on fait tourner un
ventilateur en ouvrant au pour essayer
quand même de faire un flux d'air est
d'apporter un peu d'air frais nous avons
enquêté sur les nouvelles tendances de
l'immobilier moins cher et sur leurs
abus
[Musique]
yoann est cuisinier sa compagne ses bols
sérieuse ce couple veut faire construire
une petite maison dans le val d'oise à
60 km de paris
ils ont un budget limité même s'ils
s'endettent sur 30 ans alors le budget
global on est on se situerait dans les
deux sens 2200 3000 euros en tout donc
juste en maison chercherait pas une
maison dans les cent mille euros
et après suivant le prix du terrain on
verra ce qu'on peut mettre en plus ou
pas ils ont entendu parler d'un nouveau
concept de maison low cost ce matin ils
ont rendez vous dans une entreprise de
la région de troyes lionel chouraqui on
est le dirigeant
jusqu'à maintenant ils fabriquaient des
containers destinés au transport et
aussi des cabanes de chantier depuis
deux ans il s'est lancé dans les maisons
dites modulaire
[Musique]
une fois assemblés votre module ça donne
ça donc en fait on est sur des
structures de trois mètres de hauteur
il sait que son concept peut susciter
quelques appréhensions chez ses clients
potentiels il commence toujours par
faire visiter son usine module plomberie
électricité
les logements sont entièrement fabriqués
sur place en quatre mois on va
complètement assemblée la maison ici on
va vérifier tout fonctionne ici donc
elle va être intégralement t elle va
être boulonné donc au millimètre près on
aura tous les raccords etc
elle va être testée et à ce moment là
seulement on va la déboulonner et
l'année son terme quand une nouvelle
maison sort de lusine elle est prête à
poser
celle ci a été vendu cent mille euros
les pièces du puzzle sont acheminés par
camion elles seront montées en une
journée sur les fondations pour achever
de convaincre yoann et ses bols le
patron les emmène découvrir sa toute
première construction qui date de 2010
[Applaudissements]
rentré comme à chaque fois christiane la
maîtresse de maison joue son rôle de
propriétaire comblé moi je me sens
vraiment très très bien commencé
vraiment ce qui me plaît quelque chose
d'un petit peu atypique très moderne
très lumineux on s'y sent bien
apparemment yoann est sous le charme
c'est plus compliqué que ça j'adore ces
non-dits prends tes valises aléatoire
partie une seule prise je m'en sers
depuis cette visite ils ont décidé
d'acheter une maison comme celle ci il
ne leur reste plus qu'à trouver un
terrain comme eux
deux cent mille familles optent chaque
année pour des maisons dites low cost
des constructions bâties la plupart du
temps en matériaux traditionnels qui ont
un point commun elles coûtent environ
100000 euros et jamais plus de 120000 un
marché lucratif pour des dizaines de
constructeurs petit ou plus grandes
sociétés du secteur dans leurs
publicités
un seul argument est mise en avant le
prix entre 20 et 50% de moins qu'une
maison classique
que valent vraiment ces constructions
existe-t-il des pièges dans ce nouveau
marché
sylvain baron est expert en bâtiment
chaque année ils inspectent plus de 300
maisons dont une trentaine de
construction low cost à 50 km de nantes
il a rendez vous chez les propriétaires
de ce pavillon bonjour
s'il est un baron société je viens pour
leur plan technique il y a trois ans
marie reine et roger ont quitté leur hlm
pour concrétiser le projet d'une vie
emménagé dans cette maison qu'ils ont
fait construire payé 84 1000 euros grâce
à un crédit sur 20 ans de mon point ça
correspond avait le choix entre location
et achats puis on se dit quand même on
va voir quelques jours va avoir quelque
chose à nous pas comme tout à chacun je
pense depuis quelques mois
marie-reine s'inquiète la charpente crac
la nuit la facture de chauffage lui
paraît trop élevé
l'expert va immédiatement déceler la
source d'un des problèmes je n'ai point
que je vérifie toujours ans et la
souplesse d
ouais c'est là c'est trop souple ici ça
veut dire que derrière n'est pas
d'isolant c'est pas normal ça ça c'est
pas normal
on va regarder
une autre fenêtre pour voir si on a le
même problème mais en théorie oui on a
les mêmes soucis et ben non on voyait
pas si on a ici voilà voilà aussi c'est
souple en fait c'est très souple c'est à
dire que pour mettre la plaque de plâtre
ils ont découpé la le polystyrène pour
la glisser dans la menuiserie en fait et
après moi c'est des ponts thermiques
donc le chauffage
sylvain va confirmer son diagnostic avec
une caméra thermique
les défauts d'étanchéité apparaissent au
grand jour en noir sur l'écran toutes
les zones par lesquels l'air s'engouffre
à l'intérieur l'ouvrons ben c'est pas
étanche à la là par contre il manque de
vigilance à senna
voilà mais en fait on voit bien à
travers ce hot de la menuiserie et le
coffre ils nous sommes échanges ternie
il poursuit son examen dans les combles
de la maison à charpente année fois
réellement fixée à la structure elle est
même pas fixé du tour et structures
concernés tranquille sur le mur ouais
les paquets un côté qui est fixée alors
qu'elle devrait être fixé par tous les
médecins et là on voit bien il ya des
grandes zones où il ya aucune fixation
non sap a été fixée les nécessités fixé
à la charpente charpente mal fixée
défauts d'isolation sylvain bar on sait
que ces conclusions vont être difficiles
à entendre par les propriétaires
ok bon
construction on pourrait dire un petit
peu que ces épaves thermiques mais pas
loin c'est à dire quoi c'est un gros mot
mais c'est à dire que vont pour obtenir
un 21 degrés par moins 5 au lieu de
dépenser une quantité d'argent théorique
vous en dépenserait un peu plus soif
tout simplement en mettant de la bcd
lunetterie quoi pour moi c'est en
dessous de d1 mais rarement pour une
maison bleue c'est quoi donc si on vole
à revendre un jour c'est pas facile
ce bilan n'étonne pas l'expert disons
qu'on fait croire aux gens qu'il ya 80
millions peut avoir une maison
or tout le monde sait que c'est pas
possible
ou alors on triche sur quelque chose
maintenant sûr qu'on triche soit sur la
qualité des matériaux
sauf sur la qualification de la main
d'or donc à mon avis c'est un peu les
deux ou peut-être les deux à fond
ça veut dire que au bout du compte au
bout du compte on est une maison comme
comment malgré une garantie décennale
marie reine et roger ne semble pas avoir
de recours contre le constructeur de
leur maison version rénovée l'isolation
leur coûterait dix mille euros
une dépense qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
permettre
je dirais chaque maison locaux sur
lequel on est intervenu il ya forcément
un problème et et pas des moindres
puisque c'est des problèmes question
structurelle des problèmes qui sort
d'ordre d'isolation mais problème qui
sorte d'ordre de finition mais grossière
sais pas c'est pas du petit désordre
justement les mauvaises surprises du low
cost peuvent s'avérer catastrophiques
isabelle et laurent rêvait d'être
propriétaires de leur maison ils ne
peuvent plus l'habiter
en 2009 un incendie détruit une partie
de leur logement
le maçon dépêché par l'assurance
découvre alors de sérieuses malfaçons ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'on vient quasiment
jamais plus jamais aussi peu à peu le
bourdon
on vient ici simplement pour les
expertises
après l incendie il découvre que les
fondations les structures ont été bâclés
la construction menace de s'effondrer
chantier d et es ont même été posée pour
garantir la sécurité lors des visites
dans cette maison on avait fait des
peintures parquet toutes les failles en
tout les faïences on s'était bien amusé
aujourd'hui notre souhait c'est qu'elles
soient des fêtes refaite mais mais on
sait pas il faut encore attendre
attendre ça fait ça fait deux ans et
demi que ça dure leur constructeur est
désormais aux abonnés absents il
travaillait comme franchisé pour une
grande enseigne cette marque s'est
contenté de constater les dégâts c'est
compliqué quand on peut pas s'imaginer à
quel point notre père pour un incendie
mais c'est pas évident que derrière il
ya le deuxième effet kiss cool ou de
bach leur maison low cost leur a coûté
90 mille euros même à ce prix en
principe les murs devrait être lié par
des tiges d'acier cela ils sont rendu
compte qu'il n'y avait pas du tout de
faire il n'ya pas d'acier dont il n'y a
pas de chaînage mans quand on voit le
manque de chaînage quand on voit donc
les autres malfaçons comme le poteau
donc je passe je suis pas technique mais
il n'y a aucune fondation dessous alors
que c'est le poteau principale de la
maison et aujourd'hui on maintenant là
on a un des deux d'un mètre sur un mètre
de sous un mètre cube de béton espère
vraiment dessous il est posé sur le dell
la poutre et paret qui n'est pas aux
normes
les aciers sont aux normes non plus
frais d'expertisé d'avocats double loyer
pour le couple la facture s'élève à 180
milles euros
c'est deux fois la valeur de leur maison
au cours de notre enquête nous avons
recensé une dizaine de clients de la
même entreprise qui se plaignent
aujourd'hui de malfaçons at-elle
délibérément fait des économies sur la
qualité nous avons retrouvé un artisan
qui a travaillé pour cette société
il confirme une politique de
constructions au rabais
j'ai décidé d'arrêter de travailler pour
ce constructeur parce que ce n'était
plus viable même pour l'image de marque
de mon entreprise sur ces maisons là les
fondations sont dangereuses j'ai vu une
maison où les ferrailles qui était mise
dans les fondations ne correspondait pas
aux normes réclamé aujourd'hui
alors là c'est j'avais jamais vu ça à
mon avis est bon très mal vieillir les
pauvres gens dont certaines faut avoir
des soucis à venir
nous avons contacté ce grand
constructeur faute de réponse
nous nous rendons au salon de la
franchise à paris
nous avons appris que l'entreprise y
étaient présentes tous ces chantiers
sont confiés à des exploitants locaux
des franchisés sur le stand le directeur
commercial semble embarrassé par nos
questions et j'aurais vous montrer des
photos des choses qu'on a prise dans
certaines maisons des maisons par
exemple on a le poteau sans train qui
repose juste sur la barre il n'y a pas
de fondations est ce que vous êtes au
courant de ça
chose et vous en pensez quoi du travail
qui a été fait alors passer un paquet au
moment où par exemple à partir du moment
où en france j'ai fait me fait pas
pourquoi on doit faire enfermer ces
questions est ce que ce n'est pas une
pression vous mettez sur les franchisés
et du coup on gagne de l'argent ça me
gêne tirer les prix non parce que on a
un cahier des charges on leur demande de
respecter un cahier des charges avec des
prix extrêmement série soit mais on ne
demande pas de télémétrie pour témérité
le pacte groupe avoue part dit que
certains ont peut-être les mêmes
ressources propres mais c'est suicidaire
c'est pas c'est pas logique
il nous dit avoir tenté de contacter les
victimes
en vain on est signé par rapport à un
rapport à quand maintenant oui on attend
maintenant le retour en effet aux
différentes personnes n'ont pas n'ont
pas tout puisque j'en alpin on a froid
on est malheureux et pourquoi vous
n'avez pas demander à votre ancien
franchisé les contacts de ces gens de
france nous a pas fourni les cours des
comptes et du sénat
le franchisé qui les incrimine a disparu
dans la nature
ce constructeur nous a promis de prendre
contact avec les familles lésées à ce
jour il ne l'a toujours pas fait
si faire construire pour pas cher peut
s'avérer périlleux acheter son logement
dans l'ancien s'apparentent parfois au
parcours du combattant à paris
l'immobilier a atteint des sommets en
2011 le prix moyen du mètre carré a
dépassé les 8300 euros
concrètement pour un quatre pièces
comptait 7 143 milles euros ou encore 4
124 mille euros pour un logement de
seulement 52 m² pour devenir
propriétaire coûte que coûte
certains sont prêts à vivre sous terre
dans ces logements qu'on appelle des
souplex aujourd'hui à paris des agents
immobiliers se sont spécialisés dans ses
produits au ras du bitume loge de
concierge anciens commerces
fabien garcelon ne vend que des
appartements au rez de chaussée c'est ce
diable
oui on connaissait quartier avant il va
déployer tout son savoir faire pour
persuader florence et fabrizzio
d'acheter cette ancienne boutique un
local commercial sur rue et trois caves
en bonus
sur une surface brute en terme de
rénovation des gares absolument tout à
refaire on a un réseau électrique mais
qui évidemment pas aux normes à tous qui
évacuation pour léguer pour l'eau et
toilettes mais il faudra certainement d
organiser contre lui sur le compte de
l'effet et sa s'élève à combiner
l'ensemble des travaux faut compter
entre 70 et 90 millions 7 36 m² au
rez-de-chaussée
mais selon l'agent immobilier l'atout
majeur de ce logement se trouve dans sa
partie enterré alors par ici donc voir
entrer par là une des premières parties
faites attention à votre tête
il ya un tuyau on peut enlever mes vieux
caire à m 80 il va maintenant tenter de
convaincre le jeune couple des bons
côtés de la vie souterraine
c'est très frais l'été c'est bientôt
agréable l'hiver c'est le principe de la
carpe ou si le souplex s'il a bien été
aménagés quelque chose en termes
d'énergie qui est pas très porteuse et
qui reste des pièces qui sont très
agréables
il passera assez rapidement sur les
contraintes juridiques un souplex chacun
fait ce qu'il veut de dents on avait
droit de dormir invité les gens dans
votre cave officiellement les souplex
ont pour des pièces annexes
donc pour un bureau toujours un stockage
pour faire de la musique comme vous sur
l'objectif la seule limitation mais vous
êtes propriétaire vous nous faites ce
que vous voulez chez vous la seule
limitation c'est en termes de location
vous ne pourrez jamais loué cette
surface enterré comme une chance et on
va les voir la deuxième fait attention
par à votre tête
fabien préfère mettre l'accent sur le
potentiel les trois-quarts peuvent être
réunies à condition de réaliser des
travaux supplémentaires
juste une porte non mais jusqu'à ou dans
ces cas là c'est possible d'ouvrir le
parce que si tu dois 185,5 donc on sera
pas sur du standard bah vous baisserez
un peu là je peux pas soit c'est quand
je vous disais en introduction sur ce
genre de bien il ya toujours quelques
contraintes ouais il faut faire un peu
avec les cons après si on arrive à pas
plus domaine 85 à 90 82 15 15 13 13
fabrizzio s'inquiète aussi de cette
énorme tuyau qui traversent ce qui
pourrait être son futur salon ça c'est à
la copropriété oui ça c'est tout et est
du coup d'évacuation je prends de
l'immeuble qui est derrière ça vous
pouvez pas touché c'est pour ça qu'à
autant cacher que notre agent immobilier
a réponse à tout une fois aménagé
l'appartement reviendrait au minimum à
340 mille euros pour 56 m² dont plus du
tiers en sous sol
vendre des biens de ce type ne pose pas
de problème à fabien garcelon temps
qu'il a des clients prêts à les acheter
sur ce bien on a énormément de visite on
a programmé une quinzaine de visites en
douze heures de commercialisation sur ce
bien d'autres agents immobiliers met en
garde contre cette nouvelle voc du
souplex c'est le cas de pierre antoine
ménez il va nous accompagner lors d'une
visite nous avons repéré l'annoncent
d'un particulier qui mentionne un trois
pièces atypiques de 44 mètres carrés
nous filmons en caméra cachée il ne
s'agit en fait que d'un petit studio
ça fait combien de mètres carrés la
partie ni s'ils savaient pas ce qu'ils
veulent on fait sien monsieur clark
on peut défendre le reste des mètres
carrés se situe à la cave canon ses
fenêtres ne peuvent pas s'ouvrir
manifestement aucune aération n'est
prévue dans ce qui tient lieu de chambre
prix de vente 375000 euros
à l'issue de la visite pierre antoine
ménez est dubitatif 44 m² pour 30 15000
euros
sur le papier c'est pas idiot maintenant
une fois que je sais que je vais mettre
carré donc pratiquement la moitié en
sous sol je suis quand même beaucoup
plus inquiet je pense que on devrait
tourner plutôt brutalement comme ça ou
bien maximum trois cent mille euros et
encore pour quelqu'un qui a besoin d'un
souplex qui veut acheter à souplex
j'aurais tendance en tant que
professionnel mois lui déconseiller
pour lui il s'agit d'un mauvais
investissement c'est pas possible
trop dangereux alors pourquoi sinon
jours parce que le marché est en train
de se retourner doucement on pense à des
baisses de prix qu ils oscilleront entre
5 et 10% mais sur une moyenne de prix
donc les biens sans défaut les biens
beaux continueront à se maintenir à un
prix raisonnable
par contre les ce qui va faire baisser
la moyenne sont sont les biens comme ce
minable mais bien à gros défaut c'est
bien gros défaut risque de prendre 25%
donc acheter aujourd'hui est bien comme
ça avec un tel risque c'est beaucoup
trop dangereux
il y a seulement quelques mois
de telles baisses semblait impossible
dans certaines zones
elles sont déjà bien réels comme en
lorraine dans cette région sinistrée
les prix ont chuté de 10% en 2011
la crise est une aubaine pour les
acheteurs dans leurs recherches ils
peuvent compter sur des agents
immobiliers d'un nouveau genre paris
vient bonjour marie vien n'a pas de
bureau
elle travaille de chez elle elle fait
partie de l'un de ces réseaux de
mandataires qui bouscule le marché oui
avec un sous sol complet de 200 m² 1
c'est vraiment un gros sous le sous sol
c'est assez exceptionnel
ces réseaux qu'on appelle low cost aux
méthodes plus agressive elle est
indépendante je n'ai pas de salaire je
n'ai pas de revenus je veux dire
ponctuelles tous les mois contrairement
en agence ou on a un fixe où on a le
statut salarié vrp et donc une garantie
de revenus sait jamais de quoi est fait
le lendemain en fait chaque jour
marie parcours des dizaines de
kilomètres sur les petites routes de
lorraine
elle doit décrocher au minimum une vente
par mois pour gagner de quoi vivre
maria aragon revendre mois dernier
donc c'est sûr que là voilà ce mois ci
c'est déjà plus difficile on arrive à la
fin du mois il n'y a toujours pas de
vente de propositions d'achat ou de
compromis signé les acheteurs en fait il
y en a en ce moment mais ils sont pas
ils sont pas pressés déjà de toute façon
ils attendent je sais pas quoi pour
séduire les acheteurs
elle sait que l'argument décisif
aujourd'hui plus que jamais c'est le
prix
d'accord on semble ses premiers clients
cherchent une maison ils connaissent le
contexte ils n'auront aucun scrupule à
négocier face à fait la même superficie
la maison vient d'être mise en vente
sans 25000 euros la visite à peine
commencé le couple de mondains rabais et
pas des moindres
il faut que position moi je veux dire
moi avons fait une proposition moi je
transmets aux propriétaires après pour
préfère quitter si ça dépassera pas 110
ouais ouais ce que je pense c'est aussi
embêtant si on faisait une offre
aujourd'hui à 110000 euros je pense
qu'ils diraient non il faudra attendre
personnellement donc mon niveau je vous
dirais que je connais pour prier terre
je connais la situation
je pense qu'il va réfléchir pour elle
pas question de laisser échapper une
vente
quitte à se montrer insistante ya des
acheteurs
voilà surtout ils sont rares donc comme
ici où là il faut pas il faut pas les
laisser partir ces derniers temps
marie consacre une bonne partie de ses
tournées à convaincre ceux qui lui ont
confié la vente de leur logement de
baisser leurs prix deuxième rendez vous
de la journée avec les propriétaires de
cette maison située dans un petit
village se met en marche toujours
bonjour vous avez bien sylvie et son
mari eric ont contracté un prêt relais
pour l'achat d'une nouvelle maison
on joue depuis la mise en vente de
celle-ci en juillet dernier ils ont
accepté de revoir leurs prix à plusieurs
reprises il en demande 170000 euros
elle va les inciter à baisser encore une
fois un point que je voulais voir avec
vous par rapport à là où au prix de
vente
parce que c'est vrai que chaque fois je
veux dire on fait des visites et vous
dit toujours que bon ben vous êtes prêt
à discuter au niveau du prix je veux
dire c'est pas un prix ferme qu'on
affiche que j'annonce aujourd'hui donc
mais je me demandais en fait si c'était
pas mieux de de descendre de baisser au
niveau du prix comme vous êtes en prêt
relais c'est quand même une situation
délicate parce que c'est vrai que chaque
fois vous vous dites on baissera en
baissera
mais jusqu'à combien quoi en fait donc
là on va faire jouer 165 voilà oui
donc on communique sur le voilà c'est
sûr qu'on passe on passe encore un
niveau en dessous je veux dire cinq
mille euros c'est énorme c'est énorme ça
permettrait justement je vous dire de 1
de faire les travaux ici puisqu'on a
quand même une cuisine je veux dire à
rénover marie n'en restera probablement
pas là en sept mois le couple n'a reçu
que quelques visites mais aucune
proposition
elle sait qu'ils sont prêts à faire
encore des concessions moi justement ce
que j'attends c'est que bon il ya un
lien
je suis apprécié tant de maisons est
tombé ce prix là ont déçu pour l'instant
on n'a rien si marie parvient à vendre
leur maison
elle ne leur demandera que 3 % de
commission au lieu des 6 à 7 % réclamés
par les agences classiques nouveaux
agents développement des maisons low
cost acheteur prêt à tous les sacrifices
les français n'ont pas renoncé à leur
rêve de propriétaire tous espèrent
désormais que la baisse de l'immobilier
tant de fois annoncée finissent un jour
par devenir bien réel